c'est un chemin difficile et sinueux qui
mène jusqu'au diadème une couronne
remise à Dijon cette année devant
Floriant qui a obtenu plusieurs billets
pour la cérémonie Miss France 3 4 5 6 7
c'est le GR d'en avoir 7 de billets pour
Miss France c'est le GR c'est surtout la
chance au vu du nombre de personnes
contenté d'avoir les places on est super
content car en octobre 8000 personnes
conna pour acheter leurs billets les
2000 places disponibles partent en un
quart d'heure seulement Florient et ses
amis se sont installés sur tris
ordinateur pour obtenir le sésame il y a
le côté folklore aussi le côté show qui
qui nous intéresse aussi c'était aussi
un un délire entre amis parce que tous
les ans on regarde ensemble le le show à
la télévision au départ 11 proches de
Floriant veulent assister à la cérémonie
mais cinq se désiste envoyant le prix de
la place 80 €. financièrement je le
comprends aussi que c'est un budget
après chacun conçoit ce pour nous c'est
un plaisir d'y aller c'est vraiment un
divertissement il y en a qui vont
préférer aller assister un concert nous
c'était l'occasion d'assister à un show
de 3h
80 € la même somme que l'année dernière
pour la cérémonie organisée à châurou
mais ce n'est pas le comité Miss France
qui décide du
[Musique]
prix nous ne nous occupons pas du
montant du billet ce sont les
municipalité qui fixe le
prix car c'est 10 gens qui payent
l'hébergement des candidate et du
personnel Miss France soit 50 personnes
le zénite est également mobilisé pour
l'événement et sera bloqué pendant une
semaine budget total pour la ville
430000 € financé à hauteur de 360000 €
par le mesenat et la billetterie donc le
reste à payer pour la commune sera de
€ ça permettra à la ville de Dijon et
bien de montrer à l'ensemble des
téléspectateurs et bien nos tout notre
ville notre attractivité la cité de la
gastronomie le musée des Beaux Arts et
puis peut-être faire venir enfin c'est
sûr des des futur touristes dans notre
belle ville Miss France c'est l'une des
émissions les plus suivies à la
télévision 7 million et demi de
téléspectateur en moyenne et cette année
10 minutes d'images de 10 gens seront
diffusé les candidates tourneront des
clips dans la ville elles illumineront
aussi les décorations de Noël ça fait
venir des gens et puis pas que Miss
France soit pas sur des gens c'est une
occasion de faire parler de la ville de
permettre aux gens de découvrir la ville
de venir visiter la ville donc très
belle opération ça peut être bien mais
la cérémonie elle-même des Miss France
mettre en avant à notre époque des
valeurs physiques et cetera voilà je
suis pas je partage pas l'image
véhiculée par le concours c'est
également ce que dénonce cet élu
d'opposition à la ville de
Dijon il s'agit quand même de de faire
défiler des femmes en maillot de bain
devant un jury euh pour moi ça n'a rien
de d'un d'un concours féministe si le
prétexte c'est de faire parler de Dijon
on aurait pu se distinguer comme une
ville qui refuse d'accueillir ce
concours et qui est réellement féministe
quand on a une position féministe on
l'assume dans tous les domaines
interrogé la ville répond que le
concours a évolué avec des tests de
culture générale et d'éloquence et reste
un événement populaire
incontournable lors de la dernière
soirée Miss France à 10 jours
2000 nuit avaient été réservé dans les
hôtels de la ville c'était en 2013 cette
annéelà c'est Flora coqurel qui avait
remporté le mythique diadè